petrocotin says ukraine zaparisia
nuclear plant faces a serious danger of
radioactive meltdown he says he believes
the russian military occupying the plant
is shelling it to disconnect it from the
ukrainian power grid and reconnect it to
a power system in russian-controlled
crimea taking all the power with it
they have already cut three of the four
connections to the ukrainian grid he
says and if they sever the fourth that
poses a serious nuclear risk is a risk
of
losing the external power to the plan
and it is dangerous because
there will be then
blackout mode and they will be starting
diesel generators and
if they stop then you will have like
melting of
the nuclear core of reactors
he's asking for the plant to be declared
a demilitarized zone monitored by the
international atomic energy agency out
of control of the russian army
the foreign ministers of the g7 group of
industrialized nations agree they say
it's russia's presence at that plant
that's endangering it and they've issued
a statement demanding that russia leave
and turn over control to ukrainian
authorities
the russians in turn blame the
ukrainians for putting the plant at risk
by firing on the facility
britain's defense ministry predicts the
invasion is about to enter a new phase
with the heaviest fighting shifting 350
kilometers to the front line that
stretches from zapposia to hersone
nearby in battle scarred mikolayev
residents have emerged from a 54-hour
curfew
they've come out to queue up for water
and food in a region that's been the
target of russian bombs since the
invasion began in february
ludmila statifa is among the thousands
of displaced people evacuating
chevchenkova village near hasan now
under russian control the daily
bombardment is taking its toll
of course people are afraid but everyone
is hoping that they will not reach us
and things will get better but many
houses in our village are destroyed and
people have died
there are a hundred fifty thousand
people in the city and the red cross
says all need some kind of help john
hendren al jazeera keith